what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading onto my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
so with today being our DC rebirth day I
was trying to figure out what story I
wanted to cover and and I just kind of
came to the conclusion that with it's
just having wrapped up better than
Batman
you know Nightwing vol 1 we could really
just jump into Nightwing vol 2 because
this is a two issue story arc and so
this video is going to be pretty short
and the reason behind this is because
this is really just Tim Seeley coming
along and retconning a bit of history
for Nightwing but also wrapping up the
conclusion of better than Batman so this
is really more akin to like a two issue
epilogue more so than anything else but
it's still considered to be its own
separate story because what this does is
it gives something the Nightwing is very
much needed in a new 52 which is
effectively a villain of his own now
Nightwing as part of spiral which was a
spy organization that he was working for
during the events of Grayson that gave
him different villains to go against but
when we sit down and we look at
prominent heroes in comic books whether
it's Marvel DC valued or otherwise we
look at the idea of them having a
villain alter their own you know a
character by themselves for example and
valuing comics with Harbinger Peter Stan
checks main villain is Toyo Harada when
it comes to Batman his main villain is
the Joker with Charles Xavier its
juggernaut a lot of these heroes a lot
of these characters have their own
signature villains
Nightwing didn't really seem to have
that granted the most notable villain
that he has is really like Deathstroke
but the problem with this is Deathstroke
was really a main villain of Nightwing
by way of the Teen Titans as opposed to
Nightwing himself and so what Tim Seeley
does is he says here is going to be
night wings main villain his main bad
guy and it's actually Raptor now
following out a vol.1 following out of
our video on that we had talked about
how raptor had a very different approach
to Batman where Batman said that you
know criminals need to be held
responsible to justice
they need to be held responsible for
their actions within the confines of the
justice system
you know we after said this is kind of
nonsense this is this is ridiculous he
very much took a Ra's al Ghul approach
from the the Batman Begins movie where
Raptor more or less said that the fact
that villains can basically prey on the
justice system to serve their time and
then go free is the reason why they stay
villains because there's really no
ultimate price to pay for their actions
the only Tommy would never really see
Batman
a villain as if there was absolutely no
other choice if they were so
incorrigibles read in the existence of
all things but with the Joker penguin
two-face is routinely catching these
characters throwing him in Arkham Asylum
they escape in some form or another and
then they just kind of you know repeats
us so much it's a dog chasing his tail
and while Batman does recognize that
while he does realize that he's
basically just doing the same thing day
in and day out that's the role he plays
that's the part he plays as being a
superhero in Gotham City and so
Nightwing had very much adopted this
mantle but what Tim Seeley does here is
he basically got to turns things on
their head with regards to how Nightwing
is going to perceive the world initially
we pick up with with some of the
Parliament of owls with a few members in
the Parliament the reason why we do this
is because again the last story wrapped
up with Dick Grayson and Raptor working
together to bring down the Parliament of
owls this worldwide version of the court
of owls and they had basically collected
a book of wisdom from dr. Leviticus
which had these coins that contained the
identities of these are different people
from the Parliament of owls now the the
Book of Wisdom was handed over to spiral
which decoded the decoded the book and
then handed the information over to the
authorities the problem with this was
that Raptor was a double agent he
basically used Dick Grayson and he had
used it Grayson on behalf of Cobra a
clandestine organization bent on world
domination and looking to eliminate its
own competitors and because of the fact
that the Parliament of owls was a
competitor with Raptor working for Cobra
he basically had dr. laviticus install a
backdoor meaning that whenever it was
that spiral decoded the names of these
different people from from the
Parliament of owls those names were sent
over to Cobra and they would send their
henchmen to kill off the different
members of the Parliament and that's
exactly what happens here now the other
half of this equation is that we also
pick up with with Nightwing and a guy
named Tiger now this guy is not to be
confused with bronze tiger bronze tiger
is a totally different character is not
a recreation it's not a reimagining
Tiger is basically just one of the
henchmen or one of the guys that worked
for Spiral alongside Dick Grayson as
well as a couple other people but this
is really just Tim Seeley telling us
that the experiences that Nightwing had
the allies ephors alliances with during
his time as a spy are still there and
still in existence and he still calls on
there
from time to time but once they realize
what it is it's going on once they're
informed by spiral itself that Cobra
that a back door was installed in the
book of wisdom and that Cobra had been
setting their henchmen to kill off the
Parliament of owls when they get to
where the parliament is supposed to be
having their meeting everybody in the
parliament and the Sydney branch is
killed off there they're dead and so
because of this
Nightwing comes to the realization the
Raptor had basically used him that
Raptor had duped him now we'll find out
why once we get to the end of this story
but the next part of this doesn't really
allow a whole lot of exposition it
doesn't really have a whole lot of
analysis and so it's just really one of
these things where Nightwing goes and
confronts raptor you know he says what's
what's going on you know you used to be
here and Raptor essentially just says
hey man you're naive you know like you
you are naive in terms of how the world
really exists you've been living as part
of the silver spoon of Batman and yes
you've seen some bad things but you've
seen some bad things from the
perspective of a rich guy you haven't
seen bad things from the perspective of
a poor guy and so he says the world that
you know as it exists right now is not
really the world that you see not only
that Dick Grayson while he's fighting
against Raptor is thrown into another
room and as he begins to analyze this
room he realizes that there's newspaper
clippings
there's magazine articles there's all
kinds of information that basically
chronicles his life from the time that
he was adopted by Bruce Wayne up until
the time that he left to become
Nightwing and even up to the current day
and so basically Raptors been tracking
him his whole life now something else to
point out here is that in the you know
better than Batman story arc raptor had
made a passing reference to the fact
that he knew dick Grayson's mom but
there was really nothing expanded on
this Tim Seeley didn't really do
anything with it the reason why is
because he's doing that now he really
waited for this two-part story to bring
it in and so because of the fact that
Raptor is such a capable fighter and
because of the fact that in truth dick
grace is actually holding back because
part of him believes in what it is at
raptors talking about raptors able to
get the upper hand and in doing so he
essentially incapacitates it now from
here we transition over to Bruce Wayne
now this is not some great big huge
higher meaning scenario this is really
just Tim Seeley setting the stage for
the final fight between Nightwing and
Raptor and what happens this Raptor
quite literally just shows up he just
shows up a Bruce Wayne when he's in the
middle of getting ready to do a a public
press meeting and so on and he fights
through every single security guard he
fights through all the people who were
supposed to be protecting Bruce you know
he disables every
one of them and he basically tells Bruce
Wayne you are a reflection of everything
wrong with society you're the top 1% you
really don't do anything to help anyone
and so the idea that Raptor says is he
effectively tells Bruce Wayne I'm going
to use you as a means to an end I'm
going to kidnap you and not we will save
you and the reason why he will do that
is because you are Batman and so this is
what this is really not you know Raptor
telling Bruce Wayne he knows who he is
he knows he's Batman he knows the fact
that he raised Bruce Wayne now this has
really seemed more akin to the fact that
you know Raptor had just been watching
them for so long and it really just made
sense right you know it really seemed
reasonable they wrapped her watching
them for so long that he would draw that
conclusion and that's usually what
happens when it comes to comes to these
kind of characters in DC Comics whenever
it comes to a situation whereby you know
someone deduces the identity of Bruce
Wayne as Batman either it's someone
who's been walking watching him for you
know years or someone who is wildly
intelligent and so what we do is we
switch over to tonight wing as he's
basically travelling back you know as
he's going to locate Bruce Wayne now
initially Damian Wayne wants to join him
but night.we basically says no this is a
family affair this is me and it's this
guy it's personal and Damian Wayne
respects them enough to say okay fine
then you go take care of him because in
truth Damian knows that when it comes
down to it Dick Grayson would sacrifice
his life to make sure that Bruce Wayne
lives that's just who Dick Grayson is
that's the respect that he has for Bruce
now with regards to Bruce himself
Raptor basically just says hey like I
know everything about you guys I'm
watching you for years there's no secret
you have that I don't know not only that
he also says I know all your tips and I
know all your tricks but as we know with
Bruce Wayne he always has an ace up his
sleeve
Batman always has that one thing that no
villain ever suspects now outside of
comics should I imagine Batman fans
might get a little irritated with me on
this but outside of comics in terms of
writing it's just a way to give Rhys
Wayne an out but you find that with
every character you find it with
Superman where he's green kryptonite's
there and then suddenly someone comes
along and rescues you know takes two
green kryptonite away Superman's back at
100% and he beats the bad guy you know
you find that with the x-men you know
whether all being totally defeated and
then some mutant comes out of nowhere
and saves the day you know you find that
in every single scenario it's a way to
create compelling stories but it's also
a way for a writer to ensure they don't
write themselves into a hole not only
that Tim Seeley actually does this taste
for him it's not really just like hey we
just need to make sure that people know
how cool that man is we have two
publications coming out of DC right now
to tell us how awesome Batman is is a
self-titled line and it's Detective
Comics so Tim Seeley doesn't need to
show us how cool Bruce Wayne is he does
this to illustrate a point about who
Nightwing is and is at its very
fundamental core and we'll talk about
that when we get to it but with regards
to the situation right now Raptor has
Bruce Wayne hooked to this chair and
attached to a crane and what he says is
because of your kidnapping because you
basically gave yourself up selflessly
your stock margins are skyrocketing
because people are like Oh Bruce Wayne
such a great guy you know your PR team
your marketing team are using this in
order to bolster the stock and so he
says you're basically making money off
people's emotions you're making money
off their empathy this is why you're
part of the problem so he says right now
your stocks are trading at around 150
170 dollars a share when they reach $200
a share did we're going to out we're
basically gonna kill you you know it's
going to trigger device which is going
to impale you with a spoon and this is
symbolic for Raptor he says you know
Batman lives with a silver spoon and
hands reach and he says we are going to
kill you with the very thing that you
benefit from the very thing that defines
you
this silver spoon now what's so ironic
about this is that Raptor fights for the
exact same thing that Batman does it
fights for those those individuals who
can't fight for themselves
he fights for the oppressed he fights
for the poor Bruce Wayne does the exact
same thing the problem with this is that
Raptor has been overcome with insanity
and that's really what happens here a
woman why here in a second but of course
Dick Grayson arrives to fight on behalf
of fight on behalf of Batman or Bruce
Wayne and save his life now initially
the first thing he does is check and say
hey man are you cool you know and when
Bruce Wayne says I've got this you know
don't worry about it I'll get things
sorted out
Nightwing immediately turns his
attention to rafter of course the other
half of this is that Raptor literally
activates the crane and since Batman you
know a hundred feet in the air and so
the idea is that even if that we wanted
to rescue him he's distracted by Raptor
right now no but with with the fight
between the two of them this is really
Raptor trying to explain his position
but Dick Grayson doesn't initially seem
to be listening and so what happens is
Tim Seeley gives us this sort of secret
origin of Dick Grayson and telling us
that his mother was not the pur
and he was led to believe his mother was
not some kindly individual who was part
of the flying Grayson's who died after a
mobster wanted money from the circus
owner from hailey you know it wasn't the
simple thing that Dick Grayson believed
instead Raptor himself as a child had
contracted leprosy and because he
contracted leprosy he was basically a
pariah by his own people he was more or
less excommunicated the issue with this
was that the means to cure or to treat
his leprosy was being held by the
super-rich who wanted to charge
exorbitant amounts of money for those
individuals who had leprosy in order to
get the treatment they needed and so
because of this Maria the mother of big
Grayson had basically taken pity on
wraptor and instead of shying away from
him instead of rebuking him she welcomed
him and the two of them actually went to
the pharmaceutical company broke in and
took the medicine that was needed but
because they did this they saw
themselves as Robin Hood they saw
themselves going into the mayor's house
and taking whatever else it was they
wanted and then from there it was a
matter of time before they were going to
get caught and so because of this they
ended up as part of Hayley's circus
always on the move always traveling
around that way no one could ever really
find them they could never really locate
them now of course as we know Maria went
on to to have Dick Grayson but in the
eyes of Raptor he was always in the
background he was always watching events
unfold
he was always keeping a close eye on
Maria because she was the one that who
basically brought him back and so when
Dick Grayson was born when his parents
were killed wrapped her intended to step
in and be his mentor the problem with
this was that Bruce Wayne stepped in and
Bruce Wayne adopted Dick Grayson and
then in the eyes of Raptors started
raising him all the wrong ways and
saying hey like your job here is to
fight against villains while you're
going to live in the lap of luxury and
so after attempt to believe that Dick
Grayson was not a hero for the people
that Dick Grayson was a hero for the
wealthy he was throwing the poor in jail
because they were challenging the
control of the wealthy he was throwing
the poor in jail because it was possible
they were taking the money of the
wealthy now we know it's coming back
fans this is not the case but it raised
some very philosophical questions when
it comes to the the argument of you know
the 99% versus the 1% and we're not
going to get political here but the
whole purpose behind this is Tim Seeley
telling us that Raptor is passionate
about what he believes but he's also
misguided and so because of this Dick
Grayson is easily able to get the upper
hand because he's able to go to rapture
into fighting out of
Age into fighting distracted now because
Roger himself doesn't feel pain due to
the fact that the leprosy that he
contracted had basically fried his
nerves Dick Grayson is able to break his
bones
you know he's able to to basically
incapacitate him by breaking his arms
and legs and so with you know with this
this silver spoon getting ready to
impale Batman Bruce Wayne of course with
this trick up his sleeve breaks out a
bobby pin then in doing so is able to
pick the lock of this chair and avoid
death by you know from being impaled by
this spoon but he's also 100 something
feet up and so what he does is he just
drops he jumps he jumps off the chair
now of course dick Grayson's there to
catch him
Dick Grayson grabs him the reason why
this is important and of course this
immediately just picks up in the Batcave
but the reason why this matters is that
his Raptors being taken away
you know Dick Grayson says all this
happened because of me all this happened
because I so only allow myself to trust
a guy that I didn't know anything about
and Batman says that's just part of
being human that's what makes you a good
person and he says the way that I know
you're a good person is because I didn't
fall the wrote wasn't cut I didn't go
falling to my death I jumped and the
reason why I jumped is because I knew
that you were going to be there to catch
me and so this is really just Bruce
Wayne saying you know Nightwing I trust
you implicitly I trust you with my life
and if Nightwing was really somebody who
had just fallen from grace to to such an
extreme that there was no difference
between him and a villain the Batman
would have made that decision Batman
wouldn't have made that choice if he
would just climb down basically but it
was Bruce Wayne reminding Dick Grayson
of who he is it was Bruce Wayne
reminding Nightwing they know that he's
a hero he's a good guy
that no matter what Raptor says no
matter you know what he talks about with
a lap of luxury and so on and so forth
Raptors the bad guy here and that when
it came down to making the choice
between saving a life or taking a life
that while Dick Grayson could have
killed Raptor he didn't and instead he
saved Bruce Wayne so with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end this is actually a really good story
I was really really uh I really enjoyed
this I feel like you know some of the
Nightwing lighting that we're getting
right now in DC rebirth was much needed
I didn't mind Dick Grayson as a spy it
was a pretty cool story but I feel like
having him back in the role of Nightwing
which of course he'll actually go back
to blüdhaven to but heading to Grayson
back in the role of Nightwing it just
kind of feels like it's where he needs
to be he's back where he
I don't know if that makes any sense at
all I'm sure that the super hardcore
Nightwing fans will agree but you know
it's just it's you know with his
character where he is now it feels like
everything's in its proper place anyway
guys if you're new here to comics
explained make sure you hit the sub
button to become part of the Rob core
and if you guys enjoy this video drop a
like and leave me a comment down below
do you like what we're seeing with
Nightwing and DC rebirth because I'm
kind of curious but let me know what you
guys think and yeah I will catch you all
in it peace
you